we just saw rogan's new club that he's
opening in texas it's gonna be amazing
truly amazing it's gonna be really wild
you know
and i was arguing with him about austin
real estate this morning
i was saying hey man it's a little bit
of a bubble it's overvalued he's like no
it's not
you know we go back and forth like i get
it it is a cool place to live
but you know it's a little bit of a
bubble here i think
i'm looking at houses now you walk in
there's 10 houses
10 offers on every house two of the
offers
are algorithms they're not even people
like an algorithm is offered to buy this
house
i'm like oh good it just gets a but i
get to
talk to a lot of real estate uh
professionals
and what's great about realtors is that
like ben was dealing with these realtors
who do rentals and stuff and it's like
they're not even full-time realtors so
you're calling them
they're at their other job they're like
trying to get into real estate
it's like you're calling them going hey
we sent over all the documents they're
like bagging groceries
at a heb or whatever the store is here
and they're like yeah yeah good good
we're making it happen
uh they're not even realtors yet they're
they're in the process of becoming
real estate agents like they have a
license but they don't have any clients
and no money
so you're calling people that are just
doing something else they're like
nannying for a child and you're calling
them and you're like hey we're making
this happen right they're like
yeah yeah yeah and then like a child's
vomiting on them
and they have to then change the child
because that's their day job that's the
money they make
you know and then a lot of these
realtors seem
to have brain injuries uh
traumatic brain injuries many of the
women um they seem
to have autoimmune disorders
they're very sloth-like creatures uh
they kind of collapse into the couch
they
stare at you um
uh when ben comes in i always mention
his wife so they don't think we're gay
so they don't like
not sell the house to [ __ ] or jack it
up
it's good good idea if you want to come
here and be [ __ ] you're going to pay
you'll pay but i'm always like ben and
his wife moved here and then
when ben leaves the room i look at the
realtor and i go i still suck
[Laughter]
so it throws her because that's a
negotiation strategy
but no i mean the realtor we spoke to
today was a lovely woman who's
you know probably was in a car accident
i mean this woman
she's she's very sweet
but the type of sweet that someone is
when they didn't get enough oxygen at
birth
you know what i mean where it's like
they're just kind of
now i may lose the house because of that
now but that's okay
comedy first comedy first